the people asked in a recent poll are of
two minds about us and british
intelligence agencies spying on emails
and monitoring the internet is this
extrude it's not nice but I think the
media are overdoing it so feeling
medium-long disease tema that's good
they're going a bit too far it's not
quite in terrorism it's snooping whoops
no further I can't understand why this
didn't come to light much sooner forty
percent of respondents said states
should be able to monitor the internet
thirty-nine percent said they should not
the rest said they weren't sure younger
people in Germany it turns out are more
critical than older ones they fitted
it's wrong it's none of their business
everyone has a right to privacy and that
has to be respected I'm not surprised
they all do it if it's necessary they
should do it thirty-nine percent of
younger respondents say they're against
internet espionage twenty-eight percent
are in favor older people view the
matter differently while thirty-six
percent rejected forty-three percent
endorse internet espionage
in response to the recent revelations
about a third of those surveyed said
they're going to be more cautious in
using the web
you